This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是来自I-Heart的播客。由真人呈现。2%。当有电梯可用时，只有2%的人会选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在怪异的现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和抗压能力科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即TWO%。可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和说都是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾有朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《迎难而上》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对应有的惩罚。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Guys, I don't know. I feel, I don't know how I feel about my outfit. I'm trying to, I'm like trying at the leopard print today. Is this leopard print? I don't even know anymore. I don't know if I don't know if this is me. So if you see me like picking at my cardigan today, no, it's because I'm trying out a new identity is somebody bold enough to wear leopard print and I'm I'm adjusting. literally nothing to do with what we're talking about, like literally nothing. Today, we are going to tackle the biggest question on the internet of the era. Are friendships supposed to be inconvenient? How much can we actually expect and demand from our friends? And have we come to expect too little from people in our lives? I am sure that you have seen this phrase out there recently online,
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时经历的最大改变、重要时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。伙计们，我不知道。我觉得，我不知道自己对这套衣服感觉如何。我正在尝试，我今天尝试穿豹纹。这是豹纹吗？我都不知道了。我不知道这到底是不是我。所以如果你看到我今天一直在扯开衫，不，那是因为我正在尝试一种新身份——一个有胆量穿豹纹的人，我正在适应。这跟我们谈论的内容毫无关系，真的是毫无关系。今天，我们将探讨这个时代互联网上最大的问题。友谊本该是不方便的吗？我们究竟能对朋友有多少期待和要求？我们是不是对生活中人们的期待变得太低了？我敢肯定你最近在网上看到过这句话，
and specifically on TikTok, maybe on Instagram, inconvenience is the cost of community. Or another one that's very similar is, everybody wants the village, nobody wants to be the villager. These terms, these phrases have been really hard to miss, and I think they're pointing towards this big realization that we're having as a society that, you know, the past 20 years have made us one of the most isolated generations in history.
特别是TikTok上，也许还有Instagram，不方便是建立社群的代价。或者另一句非常相似的话是，人人都想要村庄，却没有人想当村民。这些词语、这些短语真的很难不注意到，我认为它们指向了我们作为一个社会正在产生的重大认识，你知道的，过去20年让我们成为了历史上最孤立的几代人之一。
There has been, you know, the proliferation of social media that was meant to make us less lonely has made us lonelier. And a lot of wellness content has really focused on protecting our peace and boundaries, but has any of that actually made us happier? If we were to look at any loneliness survey, any loneliness study, any life satisfaction survey taken in the last five years, the answer is pretty, obviously, no, we are not happier. Loneliness has literally been labeled the modern health epidemic in the same class as diseases like COVID or Ebola or the flu. And the younger you are, the more connected you are ironically, or you should be due to technology, the more likely you are to report feeling increasingly isolated. Now, obviously, there are a lot of factors going on here. you know, the pandemic in particular interrupted a huge developmental stage for a lot of us when we were
你知道的，社交媒体的激增本来是为了让我们不那么孤独，结果却让我们更孤独了。很多健康内容真正关注的是保护我们的平静和边界，但这些真的让我们更快乐了吗？如果我们看一下过去五年中进行的任何孤独调查、任何孤独研究、任何生活满意度调查，答案非常明显，没有，我们并没有更快乐。孤独甚至被贴上了现代健康流行病的标签，与新冠、埃博拉或流感等疾病同属一类。讽刺的是，你越年轻，由于技术原因你本应联系越紧密，你就越有可能报告自己感到日益孤立。现在，显然这里有很多因素在起作用。你知道的，特别是大流行打断了我们许多人在某个重要发展阶段的发展，当时我们
typically meant to meet a lot of our lifelong friends, you know, again, social media, our smartphones, they are highly addictive, they've made it a lot harder to connect in person, but how much of it is because we have become selfish community members? You know, I've had some moments with people in the last few months, personally, that have really made me start asking this question myself. Am I asking too much of my friends or do I just need better friends? You know, there have been so many moments since moving to London and since Netflix happening where I'm like, you know, do I actually deserve more? Am I putting up with not enough?
原本应该去结交许多一生的朋友，你知道的，还有社交媒体、我们的智能手机，它们让人高度上瘾，让面对面的交往变得更加困难，但其中有多少原因是因为我们已经变成了自私的社群成员呢？你知道的，过去几个月里我和一些人经历了一些时刻，这些时刻真的让我开始自己提出这个问题。我对朋友的要求是不是太高了？还是我只是需要更好的朋友？你知道的，自从搬到伦敦以及Netflix事件发生以来，有太多时刻让我觉得，你知道的，我真的值得拥有更多吗？我是不是忍受得不够？
Am I putting up with less? And how much is that me? How much is that my expectations? How much is that my fault? and how much is it because maybe overnight our expectations for friendships have changed? And that has been a really hard pill to swallow. And one I'm still kind of confused by myself. So of course, I thought I would take this conversation and this rumination out of my mind and give it to you guys.
我是不是忍受得太少了？这其中有多少是我自身的原因？多少是我的期望值问题？多少是我的错？又有多少是因为也许在一夜之间，我们对友谊的期望发生了变化？这是一个很难接受的事实。而且我自己也还在为此感到困惑。所以当然，我一直在思考并想把这个对话从我脑海中拿出来，分享给你们。
And hopefully you can decide what we should be doing based on our discussion and the psychology we introduce today. So without further ado, let's get into it. So I thought that we'd start this episode by actually going through the psychological research on what makes a good friend, but also what is needed for a friendship to survive. Because I don't think anybody teaches us this, but it is such valuable knowledge. There have been so many attempts to categorize good friendship over the years. But my favorite one is by the social researcher, Deborah Oswald, who in the. 2016 published an entire meta-analysis on maintaining long-lasting friendships. And she looked at studies from years and years and years of psychology and what she found.
希望大家能根据我们的讨论和今天引入的心理学知识，来决定我们该做些什么。所以废话不多说，让我们切入正题。我想这一集我们可以从回顾关于什么样的人是好朋友的心理学研究开始，同时也探讨友谊得以维系需要什么。因为我认为没有人教过我们这些，但这些知识太宝贵了。多年来，有许多试图将好朋友分类的尝试。但我最喜欢的是社会研究员黛博拉·奥斯瓦尔德（Deborah Oswald）的研究，她在2016年发表了一项关于维持长久友谊的完整元分析。她研究了多年心理学研究中的种种发现。
Her conclusion was that lasting friendships need four things to survive. Positivity, openness, supportiveness, and interaction. Positivity is essentially, we need somebody who's going to make us feel better about ourself, better about our lives. Openness means we want people who are vulnerable, who are responsive, who share. Supportiveness means just classically, like people need to be there for you in good times and in bad times as well, not just emotionally, but physically, which is very important for the discussion we're having today. And finally, interaction. Interaction doesn't have to be in person. It doesn't have to be every week. But there is some kind of minimal level
她的结论是，持久的友谊要生存需要四个要素：积极性、开放性、支持性和互动。积极性本质上是，我们需要一个能让我们对自己、对生活感觉更好的人。开放性意味着我们需要脆弱、敏感、乐于分享的人。支持性则很经典，即人们需要在你顺境和逆境时都陪伴在你身边，不仅要在情感上，还要在物理上，这对我们今天的讨论非常重要。最后是互动。互动不一定非得是面对面的。它不需要每周都有。但必须达到某种最低水平
of contact required before a friendship is deprioritized in our lives or just like fades altogether. Now, this number, this level of interaction changes based on where you are in your friendship, obviously, when you're first establishing a friendship, that is where the biggest time investment is taking place. A 2018 study found that it takes about 50 hours to shift from acquaintances to casual friends, 90 hours to call someone a good friend, over 200 hours plus to call somebody a really close friend. Even that is kind of at the lower end. So obviously when you're first making a friend, you need to see each other quite frequently to kind of maintain that bond. But in terms of
的接触，否则友谊就会在我们的生活中被降级，或者直接消逝。当然，这个数字、这种互动水平会根据你处于友谊的哪个阶段而改变，显然，当你刚建立一段友谊时，正是投入最多时间的阶段。2018年的一项研究发现，从熟人转变为泛泛之交大约需要50小时，称某人为好朋友需要90小时，而称某人为真正的挚友则需要200多小时以上。即便如此，这其实也只是在较低的水平上。所以显然，当你刚交朋友时，你需要经常见面来维持这种纽带。但就
maintenance, the maintenance of a long-term friendship, we actually don't have that much research about how often we should be interacting. And maybe that's part of the broader social problem here. We're all very interested in making friends, in surrounding ourselves with people. But once we have them, I think it's a lot easier to kind of take them for granted and not be putting in those maintenance hours. My take is the longer the friendship, the more time between interactions online or in person you can kind of get away with, especially if they're a long distance friend. I also think my personal opinion, again, is that in-person hours count for triple online hours in terms of quality time. But it's funny that, you know, as soon as we get to this discussion of like, what does it take to be a good friend? We immediately discuss minimums here.
维系而言，长久友谊的维系，我们实际上并没有关于我们应该多久互动一次的那么多研究。也许这也是这里更广泛的社会问题的一部分。我们都对交朋友、与人相处很感兴趣。但一旦我们有了朋友，我认为就很容易把他们视为理所当然，不再投入那些维系的时间了。我的看法是，友谊越长久，线上或线下互动之间可以间隔的时间就越长，特别是对于异地朋友。我也认为，再次声明，这只是我的个人意见，就高质量时间而言，面对面的时间抵得上在线时间的整整三倍。但有趣的是，你知道的，一旦我们开始讨论“成为一个好朋友需要什么”这个话题，我们就会立刻开始讨论最低标准。
You know, we immediately are like, what's the minimum amount we should be seeing our friends? When, in fact, you should want to see your friends as much as possible. You shouldn't just be looking for the minimal number of hours to pour into somebody so that, they will be there for you when you really need them. So that was a tangent. Let's return to the original research. Positiveity, openness, supportiveness and interaction. That's what a friendship needs to survive.
你知道的，我们立刻就会问，我们见朋友的最低频率应该是多少？而事实上，你应该尽可能多地想见到你的朋友。你不应该只是寻找向某人倾注的最少时间，好让他们在你真正需要的时候出现。刚才扯远了。让我们回到最初的研究。积极性、开放性、支持性和互动。这就是友谊生存所需的条件。
Something, though, that these factors all have in common that comes back to this broader question we're asking today is that all of these things are quite time intensive and sacrificial and difficult at times. It's difficult to always be supportive. It's difficult to always be there for your friends. But if you are missing even one of these things for too long, a friendship is going to fade. Friendships are not, at least my friendships are not, some evergreen tree you can plant and leave, and they will stay the same forever for your return, especially not friendships that are early on in their lives.
不过，这些因素都有一个共同点，这也回到了我们今天提出的更广泛的问题：所有这些事情都相当耗费时间、需要牺牲，有时也很困难。总是给予支持是很困难的。总是陪伴在朋友身边是很困难的。但如果你哪怕缺少其中一样太久，友谊就会消逝。友谊不是，至少我的友谊不是那种你可以种下后就不管不顾的常青树，它们不会永远保持原样等你回来，尤其是那些刚刚建立不久的友谊。
This is where our problem emerges. It is so much easier to be that kind of detain. touch friend and to only devote our energy and our time to ourselves. It is so much easier, whether you're an introvert or an extrovert, like, we're all tired. It's so much easier to spend time alone and to not be annoyed or inconvenienced by other people's problems, but you are almost guaranteeing loneliness that way. And this really brings us naturally to the big question of the day. Why is our preference for being alone? Why is it that we have come to expect less from our friendships and also inadvertently desired to give less. Like what has changed in recent decades that
我们的问题就是这样出现的。做那种若即若离的朋友，只把精力和时间留给自己，要容易得多。无论你是内向还是外向，真的，我们都很累。独处，不被别人的问题所烦扰或打扰，要容易得多，但你这样做几乎就是在确保自己会感到孤独。这自然把我们引向了今天的大问题。为什么我们更喜欢独处？为什么我们对友谊的期望降低了，同时又在无意中渴望付出更少？近几十年来究竟发生了什么，
has made this a trend that we're seeing? I personally think there are three distinct horsemen of like the low expectation, low effort friendship apocalypse. Three things that have done the most damage to how we create and maintain good relationships. First is the move for. from social spaces to private spaces that we're experiencing, the broader social move from social to private spaces. Second is busyness and how overworked we are. And third is, and this might be controversial, but it is the manipulation of self-help language
才让这成为了一种我们正在看到的趋势？我个人认为，低期望、低投入的友谊大末日有三个明显的“骑士”。对我们如何建立和维护良好关系造成最大破坏的三件事。首先是我们正在经历的从社交空间到私人空间的转变，即社会空间从公共走向私人更广泛的转变。其次是忙碌以及我们过度工作的情况。第三点，这可能有些争议，但它是对自我帮助语言的操纵
and self-help terms that we throw around and we don't actually understand. So let's start with number one, the move from public spaces to private spaces, including our move online, which could be deemed a public space but is often accessed privately. I read this fascinating study that said in the last 30 years, our use of public spaces has dropped by more than 14%. The time we spend in third spaces, so coffee shops, libraries, parks, pubs, just sitting and enjoying
以及我们随口乱用却并不真正理解的自助术语。让我们从第一点开始，从公共空间向私人空间的转变，包括我们向线上空间的转移，线上空间虽然可被视为公共空间，但往往是以私人的方式访问的。我读过一项迷人的研究，上面说在过去30年里，我们对公共空间的使用率下降了超过14%。我们在第三空间（即咖啡馆、图书馆、公园、酒吧）度过的时间，只是坐着享受
ourselves, being present, outdoors in public spaces, has also drastically shifted. with people spending more and more time at home. You know a really fascinating way they studied this? They looked at walking speed and walking pace as a determinant of how much time people are spending in public spaces. Obviously, if you're walking slower, you spend more time in public spaces, you're more likely to run into a neighbor or talk to somebody. If you're walking faster, efficiently, you're going to kind of pass by those minimal social interactions. our walking pace has increased by 15% in the last few years,
我们自己，保持当下，在公共空间的户外，也发生了巨大的变化，人们花越来越多的时间呆在家里的。你知道他们研究这个的一个非常迷人的方法吗？他们把步行速度和步频作为人们在公共空间度过多少时间的一个决定因素。显然，如果你走得慢，你在公共空间度过的时间就更多，你就更有可能遇到邻居或和某人交谈。如果你走得快、有效率，你就会有点错过那些最微不足道的社交互动。在过去几年里，我们的步行速度增加了15%，
meaning we are more in a rush. We are more in a rush to get from place A to place B, from work to home, home to gym, gym back home, which has, and I kind of just mentioned this, reduced our incidental exposure to other people in our community. What has replaced these times we'd usually spend out of our homes? you know, what has replaced these moments we'd usually spend with our friends? It's our phones.
这意味着我们更加匆忙。我们更急于从A地到B地，从工作到家，从家到健身房，从健身房回到家，这已经，正如我刚刚提到的那样，减少了我们对社区中其他人的偶然接触。是什么取代了我们通常花在户外的时间？你知道的，是什么取代了我们通常和朋友在一起的时刻？是我们的手机。
Our phones, our screens, our streaming services, things that are by their very nature, very private. Technology, particularly social media, which ironically promised us even more connection, has made us actually a very isolated and sanitized lives. on average, and this is an average, we spend two, two and a half hours on social media day. A lot of that is just empty time that I think often feels like we're doing something social because we're seeing the faces of other people, we're hearing their voices, we're learning about their stories, we're receiving dopamine, but it's not. And what's funny is that a big reason we don't see our friends, don't do the 40-minute commute to their side of town, don't have the evening free for them is because we think we have less free time.
我们的手机、屏幕、流媒体服务，这些东西本质上是非常私人的。技术，特别是社交媒体，讽刺的是它承诺给我们更多的连接，却实际上让我们过上了非常孤立和净化的生活。平均而言（这是一个平均值），我们每天在社交媒体上花两到两个半小时。其中很多只是空闲时间，我经常觉得这让我们感觉像是在做一些社交活动，因为我们看到了别人的脸，听到了他们的声音，了解了他们的故事，获得了多巴胺，但其实并不是。有趣的是，我们不去看朋友的一个重要原因，没有花40分钟车程去他们那边的城区，晚上没有空陪他们，是因为我们觉得自己有更少的空闲时间。
But in fact, it's because we have devoted more of that free time to phone time. A 2023 study actually found we have about the same amount of free time as we did two decades ago before the explosion of MySpace and Facebook. on average, five hours, five hours of free time a day. But we spend so much more of it online, which feels more like a necessity, and therefore means that we are becoming more and more isolated without realizing it. And I know, obviously, you guys have heard this so many times. Social media is making us more lonely. Social media is stealing our time, stealing our attention.
但事实上，这是因为我们将更多的空闲时间奉献给了手机时间。2023年的一项研究实际上发现，我们的空闲时间与二十年前MySpace和Facebook爆发前大致相同。平均每天有五小时，五小时的空闲时间。但我们有更多的时间花在网络上，这感觉更像是一种必需品，因此意味着我们在不知不觉中变得越来越孤立。我知道，显然，你们已经听过很多次了。社交媒体让我们更孤独。社交媒体正在偷走我们的时间，偷走我们的注意力。
But I think it's really important to emphasize that in an episode about how friendship has become seemingly more inconvenient when we are very easily and very much allow ourselves to be inconvenienced by our phones equally as much. The truth is though, we may have as much leisure time as we did 20 to 30 years ago. That doesn't mean we're not cognitively more exhausted and more extended during the time we are working or switched on at work to use that time effectively. And that brings me to reason number two. We may have the same amount of free time, but busyness and overall exhaustion is a big reason. We feel like the inconvenience of friendship is sometimes more of a challenge. You know, we may be working the same hours,
但我认为在这一集关于友谊如何变得看似更加不方便的节目中，强调这一点非常重要，因为我们非常容易也很大程度上同样允许自己被手机打扰。不过事实是，我们可能拥有和二三十年前一样的闲暇时间。这并不意味着我们在工作或在工作中开启工作状态时，在认知上不会更加精疲力竭、消耗更多，从而无法有效地利用这些时间。这就带我来到了第二个原因。我们可能有同样多的空闲时间，但忙碌和整体精疲力竭是一个主要原因。我们觉得友谊带来不便有时是一个更大的挑战。你知道的，我们可能工作相同的时间，
but what is expected of us during those hours is far different from before, especially as technology has, you know, driven up productivity expectations and therefore driven up cognitive fatigue. That leaves less mental energy for the things we actually want or know we should do like seeing our friends. The fact that the busyness has become more of a status symbol as well these days, which you will know all too well if you listen to our why rest makes you feel guilty episode, that hasn't helped. You know, a busy schedule, it's the new designer handbag. It's the new sports car.
但在这些时间里对我们的期望与以前大不相同，特别是随着技术（你知道的）推高了生产力预期，从而推高了认知疲劳。这留给那些我们真正想要或知道我们应该做的事情（比如见朋友）的心理能量就更少了。事实上，这些天忙碌也变得更像是一种身份象征，如果你听过我们为什么休息会让你感到内疚那一集，你就会对此非常清楚，这并没有什么帮助。你知道的，忙碌的日程安排，它是新的名牌手袋。它是新的跑车。
It makes you seem important. Having a large community simply isn't admired the same way that having a lot of money is. Or having great accolades or an amazing, important job is. I think that's changing these days. I think people are like, huh, money can't buy me happiness. It's almost like people have been saying that for years, but now I'm starting to realize it. And you can actually see that in social media trends, right? The community influencer, people who do events, people who show people where to meet others, who get off the line, they're becoming so much more popular.
它让你显得很重要。拥有一个庞大的社区根本不像拥有大量钱财那样受到赞赏。或者拥有伟大的荣誉或一份了不起的、重要的工作。我认为这些天情况正在改变。我认为人们开始觉得，嗯，钱买不到幸福。这就像人们多年来一直在这么说，但现在我开始意识到了。你实际上可以在社交媒体趋势中看到这一点，对吧？社群影响者、举办活动的人、向人们展示在哪里结识其他人、脱离网线的人，他们变得越来越受欢迎。
I think we're realizing that the allure of exhaustion is a lie. You can, again, have all the importance and money in the world, but you can't buy deep friendship. I always ask myself this question, why are we so willing? to inconvenience ourselves for a boss or for a job but not for a friend. If your boss says, hey, I need you to work till 9pm without pay, you're like, of course, right away. But if your friend asks you to come to dinner that starts after 8, you're not going to do that. You're too busy.
我想我们正在意识到精疲力竭的诱惑是个谎言。你可以再次拥有世界上所有的重要性和金钱，但你买不到深厚的友谊。我总是问自己这个问题，为什么我们如此愿意？为了老板或工作而让自己感到不方便，却不愿为朋友这样做？如果你的老板说，嘿，我需要你无偿工作到晚上9点，你就会说，当然，马上。但如果你的朋友邀请你去吃晚上8点以后开始的晚餐，你不会去。你太忙了。
You're too tired. Your boss isn't going to be the one visiting you when you're sick. Your friends are. So you've got to make that space. Let yourself be inconvenienced by your friends the way you inconvenience yourself for work. I will say it is really hard to maintain everything we are expected to maintain as adults. In a capitalist society, I know I'm receiving this message. You are receiving this message that you have to prioritize everything, do everything, be successful in everything.
你太累了。在你生病时来探望你的不会是你的老板。是你的朋友。所以你必须腾出那个空间。就像你为了工作让自己感到不便那样，也让你的朋友给你带来一些不便吧。我得说，作为成年人，维持我们被期望维持的一切真的很艰难。在资本主义社会中，我知道我正在接收这个信息。你也在接收这个信息，即你必须优先考虑一切，做好每件事，在所有事情上都取得成功。
That's impossible. So of course, some things get let go of. We fail in some aspects. And typically, because of the way that society and culture has prioritized our lives for us, Friendship seems the least important, the least necessary. That's the thing we're going to give up first. And what we're seeing is, hey, maybe the priorities we've been given, friendship at the bottom, or closer to the bottom, is not right,
这是不可能的。所以理所当然地，有些事情被放下了。我们在某些方面失败了。而且通常来说，由于社会和文化为我们优先安排生活的方式，友谊似乎最不重要，最不必要。那是我们首先要放弃的东西。而我们所看到的是，嘿，也许我们被赋予的优先级中，友谊被排在最底部，或者接近底部，是不对的，
because friendship is life-giving. And not having our friends, not having community, regardless of how inconvenient it is, does come at a cost. I feel like this is a balance or challenge we are really going to have to figure out in the next few years, hopefully. How do we balance, you know, productivity and a very, very competitive job market and making money with well-being and with one of the most inexpensive things for our well-being there is out there, which is friendship?
因为友谊能赋予生命。没有我们的朋友，没有社区，无论它有多么不便，确实是要付出代价的。我觉得这是我们在未来几年真正需要弄清楚的平衡或挑战，希望如此。我们如何在生产力和竞争激烈的工作市场以及赚钱之间，与福祉以及存在于世上最便宜的福祉之一——友谊——取得平衡？
Okay, we are going to take a show. short break here. But when we return, I want to get into that third, and I would say most controversial reason that we've, you know, shied away from the inconvenience of friendship, which is the rise of hyper-individualized therapy speak. I don't think everyone's going to be happy with what I have to say, but it's important nonetheless, stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
好的，我们要在这里休息一下。但当我们回来时，我想探讨第三个也是我认为最具争议的原因，即我们（你知道的）逃避友谊带来的不便的原因，也就是高度个性化的治疗术语的兴起。我不认为每个人都会对我要说的话感到高兴，但它依然很重要，请继续收听。《2%》。当有电梯可用时，只有2%的人会选择走楼梯。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在怪异的现代世界中培养精神坚韧、体能和抗压能力科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Persent，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMAs上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为犯罪。快克可卡因。我愿意在某天谈论快克可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid?
我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做一个好人很重要吗？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，我们进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
打开你的免费iHeartRadio App，搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，那个女同性恋，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对应有的惩罚。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Love Trapped》播客。
For a psychology podcast, again, what I'm going to say next might be a bit controversial. This is just my opinion. But I think the viral nature of so many therapy terms and therapy speak without actual education on what those terms mean and how to apply them has made us. think it's okay to be selfish for no reason. This has made us think that it is normal to just do what we want and to call it a boundary and to expect others to respond accordingly. And if they don't, we can cut them from our lives.
作为一个心理学播客，再次重申，我接下来要说的话可能会有点争议。这只是我的个人意见。但我认为，如此多的治疗术语和治疗用语在没有真正教育这些词的意思以及如何应用它们的情况下进行病毒式传播，让我们觉得无缘无故地自私是可以接受的。这让我们觉得，只做我们想做的事、并称之为边界、并期望别人做出相应的回应是正常的。如果他们不这样做，我们就可以把他们从我们的生活中切断。
Big distinction I need to make here. I'm not talking about setting boundaries for well-being or being selfish as a way to reclaim the times that you are self-less and were taken advantage of. I'm not talking about selfishness for self-protection. Love all those things. I love when people state what they need, know what they need, are open about their wants. Love that.
我需要在这里做一个重大区分。我不是在谈论为了福祉而设定边界，也不是为了收回你无私且被利用的时间而自私。我不是在谈论为了自我保护而自私。我喜欢所有这些。我喜欢人们陈述他们需要什么、知道他们需要什么、对他们的愿望坦诚。我喜欢这样。
But that's the thing. I love it because it's being communicated. It's not being dictated. I think we can all think of examples of boundaries or therapy speak being co-opted in a way that is just unfair, unreasonable and never explained, ghosting a friend over a minor disagreement, not showing up for important events because you're tired, and refusing to acknowledge someone else's disappointment in that, protecting your peace by disregarding others' feelings.
但关键就在这里。我喜欢它是建立在沟通的基础上的。而不是被支配的。我想我们都能想到一些例子，边界或治疗术语被以一种不公平、不合理且从不解释的方式滥用，比如因为一次微小的分歧而对朋友进行冷暴力，因为疲劳而没有出席重要活动，并拒绝承认别人对此的失望，以无视他人感受的方式来保护你的平静。
I've done it before. I wish I could be like the innocent person here, but we all have. I read this article though the other day from Bustle, and this is like a great example of this that I just think, There was going to be one example of this. This is the one I would use. It was this girl. Her name was Anna, I think.
我以前也这样做过。我真希望自己能成为这里那个无辜的人，但我们都做过。不过我前几天从Bustle读到了一篇文章，这就像是一个很好的例子，我想如果必须有一个这样的例子的话。这就是我会用的那个。那是一个女孩。我想她叫安娜。
Let's call her Anna. Sorry, Anna, if it's something else. But her name was Anna. She'd had this friend five years. That's a long time to have a friend in your 20s. And her friend dumped her over text whilst they were making plans, being like, I'm in a place where I'm trying to honor my needs and act in alignment with what feels right within the scope of my life. and I'm afraid our friendship doesn't seem to fit into that framework.
我们叫她安娜吧。对不起，安娜，如果叫别的名字的话。但她叫安娜。她和这个朋友认识了五年。在你二十多岁的时候，交一个五年的朋友是很长的一段时间。而她的朋友在他们正在计划事情的时候通过短信甩了她，大致意思是，我在一个地方，我正试图尊重我的需求，并采取符合我生活范围内感觉正确的行为，而且我恐怕我们的友谊似乎不符合那个框架。
I can no longer hold the emotional space you've wanted me to that kind of language, which is empowering language, but that's classic therapy speak. And that language, yes, again, it's important. Boundaries are important. But in this example, this person is missing a crucial ingredient. You can't set a boundary and not communicate it with the other person. and then only deliver the consequences. You can't expect every relationship to be purely dictated by your needs,
我再也无法承担你一直想让我承担的情感空间了——那种语言，虽然是赋权的语言，但那是典型的治疗用语。这种语言，是的，再次强调，这很重要。边界很重要。但在这个例子中，这个人缺少了一个关键成分。你不能设定了一个边界却不与对方沟通，然后直接交付惩罚结果。你不能指望每一段关系都完全由你的需求所主导，
which are never expressed before the person is cut from your life, and think or expect to have fulfilling friendships from that. It's just, it's not possible. Self-help and therapy and wellness speak and all this language has made us think that, I guess, self-improvement and healing is something that happens in isolation, or that improving our lives is all about what we can do for ourselves and what we can do to make our lives more stress-free and nervous system regulation and removing toxic energy. But I think we've overcorrected.
而这些需求在把人从你的生活中切断之前从未表达过，然后还认为或期望从中获得充实的友谊。这简直，这是不可能的。自我帮助、治疗、健康术语和所有这些语言让我们认为，我猜，自我提升和疗愈是孤立发生的事情，或者改善我们的生活完全在于我们能为自己做些什么，以及我们能做些什么来让我们的生活更无压力、调节神经系统以及消除有毒能量。但我认为我们矫枉过正了。
There was a point where we didn't have any language for this. You didn't have any knowledge about this. And so we really did need some of this language to be like, hey, that's why I feel bad. That's why I feel taking advantage of. Now we've perhaps taken this standard so far that it's isolating. It's a highly individualistic approach that, you know, I think contradicts the collective lives most of us crave. What it also doesn't acknowledge is the mere fact of human nature.
曾几何时，我们没有任何语言来表达这一点。你对此没有任何知识。所以我们确实需要一些这样的语言来表达，嘿，这就是我为什么感觉不好。这就是我为什么觉得被利用了。现在我们可能把这个标准推得太远了，以至于它变得孤立。这是一种高度个人主义的方法，你知道的，我认为这与我们大多数人渴望的集体生活相矛盾。它也没有承认人性的一个事实：
People make mistakes. You have made mistakes. You have made mistakes people have forgiven you for. People have disagreements. Relationships aren't equal all the time. and maybe the most crucial one of all, you are not the only person who has needs and you are not the most important person in a relationship or in the world. You are just a person operating in a bigger collective system and what you give to that collective, to your friends, to your family,
人会犯错。你也犯过错。你犯过别人原谅你的错误。人会有分歧。关系并非一直都是平等的。也许最关键的是，你不是唯一一个有需求的人，你也并不是一段关系或世界上最重要的人。你只是在一个更大的集体系统中运作的一个个体，你对那个集体、你的朋友、你的家人、
to your neighbors, to strangers is what you receive back. And there's still agency in that equation, right? If you want to maintain those boundaries of like, do not cross these, do not wrong me, I cannot be inconvenienced, I want a stress-free life, you're totally welcome to do that. But don't turn around and be surprised when you don't have any friends anymore or your community is, there's nothing there. The reason friendship is so beautiful and complex and nourishing and the reason community is so beautiful and complex is nourishing is because people are complex. and because they surprise us and because they are imperfect. If you want to appreciate the full beauty of that,
你的邻居、陌生人所付出的，就是你所收回的。这个等式中仍然存在主观能动性，对吧？如果你想维持那些边界，比如：不要越界，不要冤枉我，我不能忍受任何不便，我想要一个没有压力的生活，你完全可以这样做。但不要转过身来，当发现自己再也没有朋友或者你的社区空无一人时感到惊讶。友谊之所以如此美丽、复杂且滋养人心，社区之所以如此美丽、复杂且滋养人心，正是因为人是复杂的。因为他们会给我们带来惊喜，因为他们是不完美的。如果你想体会其中的全部美妙，
you also have to pay the price of being annoyed at people sometimes because they piss you off. Or inconvenienced because you don't really want to pick them up from the airport, but, you know, they did it for you the other day, so you may as well. Or the occasional frustration that comes with people being unique and individual and not exactly catered to your needs like a character and a movie. I think, I think personally, you get much more in return that way. True community is messy because humans are messy.
你也就必须付出有时会对人们感到恼火的代价，因为他们惹恼了你。或者因为你其实并不太想去机场接他们而感到不便，但是，你知道的，他们前几天为你做过，所以你最好也去一下。或者偶尔伴随着人们独特而个性化、并不完全像电影角色那样迎合你需求而带来的挫败感。我认为，我个人认为，你通过这种方式会得到更多的回报。真正的社区之所以杂乱无章，是因为人类本身就是杂乱无章的。
That's why they are wonderful. Again, you can choose the alternative. You can continue to live a life where everything is organized around your convenience. you are so welcome to do so. That's the beautiful thing about therapy and this wave of wellness and self-improvement. People have learned that they have agency
这就是它们美妙的原因。当然，你可以选择替代方案。你可以继续过一种一切都围绕着你的便利来组织的生活。你完全可以这样做。这就是治疗以及这股健康和自我提升浪潮的美妙之处。人们已经了解到他们拥有主观能动性
and their emotional choices. You have free will. But I don't think your human experience is going to be as great as it can be if you alternatively accept a little bit of discomfort. It's called the law of friction. Some of the best things in life
以及他们的情感选择。你有自由意志。但我不认为你的丰富人类体验会像你愿意接受一点点不舒服时那样美好。这被称为摩擦定律。生活中一些最美好的事物
create the most friction and discomfort, that's with friendship. With that in mind, let's talk about what it takes to be a villager these days and the ways that you can create the community you want and that you deserve, even when it's not easy. Starting with tip number one. This is the thing that dramatically, dramatically changed my friendships more than anything else. do you know when you were in high school or even primary school and you would like keep track of who messaged you for your birthday or like who posted about you on the Instagram story or like
会产生最多的摩擦和不适，友谊也是如此。带着这种心态，让我们来谈谈这些天做一个村民需要什么，以及你可以通过哪些方式去创造你想要且应得的社区，即使这并不容易。从第一条建议开始。这件事情极大地、极大地改变了我的友谊，胜过其他任何事情。你知道吗，当你还在高中甚至小学的时候，你会留意谁发信息祝你生日快乐，或者谁在Instagram快拍里发了关于你的内容，或者
Snapchat for your birthday and who didn't like I know a lot of us still do this in adulthood in a different form keeping track of whether you were the last one to reach out you were the last one to shout dinner whatever it is those little things I need you to stop doing that I know it's it feels unnatural, but I need you to stop doing that. Everything becomes a scoreboard and that eliminates the natural reciprocity that a relationship should have. There is a very famous social psychology theory that you've definitely heard on this podcast before. It's known as equity theory basically says that when we perceive that the input and output ratio in a relationship is not fair or is an unequal in friendship, it causes tension and it causes us to be uncomfortable, that's taught. That's totally.
生日时的Snapchat动态以及谁没有点赞——我知道我们很多人在成年后仍然以不同的形式这样做：记录着自己是不是最后一个联系对方的人、是不是最后一个主动请吃饭的人，无论具体是什么，我需要你们停止这样做。我知道这感觉很不自然，但我需要你们停止这样做。一切都变成了计分板，这消除了关系应有的自然互惠。有一个非常著名的社会心理学理论，你以前肯定在这个播客里听过，它被称为公平理论。基本上，该理论认为，当我们感知到一段关系或友情中的投入产出比不公平或不对等时，就会引起紧张感，让我们感到不舒服，这是可以理解的。完全可以。
totally understandable, right? Because we want to know that somebody likes us as much as we like them, that they're not taking advantage of us. But when it's the only thing you pay attention to, that's not an organic relationship. And additionally, you have to be able to view that over many years if you want long-term friendships. Sometimes a friend needs more from you, needs more of the oxygen, needs more of the time and the space to vent, needs more support, sometimes for months on end. If we are constantly weighing up the short-term stats with that, you know, checklist of who did what last, I think you may incorrectly believe that they are being a bad villager. And that's not always true. Sometimes you have to be able to get that bird's eye view
完全可以理解，对吧？因为我们想知道别人喜欢我们就像我们喜欢他们一样，他们没有在利用我们。但如果这是你唯一关注的事情，这就不是一段有机的关系。此外，如果你想要长期的友谊，你必须能够从多年的跨度来看待这一点。有时，一个朋友比平时更需要你，需要更多的氧气，需要更多的时间和空间来倾诉，需要更多的支持，有时甚至长达数月之久。如果我们总是用那个“谁最后做了什么”的短期数据清单来权衡，你知道的，我猜你可能会错误地认为他们是一个糟糕的村民。事实并非总是如此。有时你必须能够放眼全局。
of over years and years or even over decades of the flows that a relationship takes. Secondly, the second way you can be a villager is push back against your hyper-independence and ask for help. This is something I've always struggled with. And, you know, I'm a very independent person, classic, I know, eldest daughter, high achiever, don't need anyone type, moved out of home when I was like 17. I'm sure so many of you relate to this as well. It was a badge of honour to not need help with anything. what I've realized is that not letting people help me is actually doing both of us a disservice.
从几年、几年甚至几十年的跨度来看待关系中的起伏。其次，成为好村民的第二种方式是：打破你的过度独立，学会寻求帮助。这也是我一直以来都在挣扎的事情。而且，你知道的，我是一个非常独立的人，很典型的长女、高成就者、“不需要任何人”的类型，我在大约17岁时就搬出了家。我相信你们中也有很多人对此深有共鸣。不需要任何人的帮助曾是一种荣誉勋章。然而我意识到，不让别人帮我，实际上对我们双方都是一种伤害。
I struggle more. I feel more in over my head. But it's also denying someone else the opportunity they would like to show you that they love you in their way. You are denying sometimes their love language of acts of service, but also they want to do this. This is this weird thing. letting people help you as more of a gift to other people sometimes. And so not letting them do that because you think it's an annoyance to them means you're limiting them in a way. I think it's very, very hard to not feel like a burden when you ask people for help when you move or when you ask them to pick you up from the airport or to take you to doctor's appointments
我自己挣扎得更多，感觉更难以应付。但这同时也剥夺了别人以他们的方式向你展示他们爱你的机会。你拒绝了有时属于他们的“服务行动”这种爱语，而且他们其实是想这么做的。这是一种很奇怪的现象。让别人帮助你，有时对其他人来说更像是一种礼物。因此，因为你觉得这会打扰到他们而拒绝让他们这样做，意味着你在某种程度上限制了他们。我觉得，当你搬家时向别人求助，或者请他们去机场接你、带你去看医生时，要不觉得自己是个累赘，真的非常非常难。
or, you know, get up early and give you a lift somewhere. But what I found, and I want you to reflect on your own experiences here, is that any times I have been asked that, and somebody's asked me to do them a favor or to help them or to come early to the party, oh my God, I feel such like a swelling in my heart. I get so excited. I'm like, they have trusted me. They must really love me. Our friendship must be like really, really, they must think I'm a great friend. And that's a beautiful feeling. Being a villager isn't just letting others lean on you.
或者，你知道的，早起载你去某个地方。但我发现的是——我也想让你们在这里反思一下你们自己的经历——每当我被这样请求时，当有人请求我帮个忙、帮他们一个忙，或者早点来参加派对时，天哪，我的内心都会涌起一股暖意。我兴奋极了。我会想：“他们信任我，他们一定真的很爱我。我们的友谊一定真的、真的很深，他们一定觉得我是个很棒的朋友。”这是一种美好的感觉。成为一个村民，不仅仅是让别人依靠你。
It's leaning on them as well. And letting yourself be helped rather than isolating yourself further. Also, the more you maintain loyalty to your hyper-independence, the kind of the more exhausted you're going to be. And that is not going to give you the mental energy, the cognitive energy. energy to show up for others. So you have to be okay with saying, yes, I do need help and asking for help and understanding that's a gift for both people. Number three, remember the times that you were tired and you went anyways. A really important part of accepting that friendship is going to be
也是去依靠他们。让自己得到帮助，而不是让自己进一步孤立。此外，你对过度独立保持的忠诚度越高，你就会感到越疲惫。而这并不能给你提供足够的精神能量、认知能量，去照顾到别人。所以你必须学会接受：“是的，我确实需要帮助”，去开口求助，并理解这对双方来说都是一份礼物。第三点，记住那些你很累但还是去了的时刻。接受友情将会有所不便这一事实的一个非常重要的部分是
inconvenient is remembering that that inconvenience still brings with it a reward. Reflecting on your own memories and looking back in the past and distinctly keeping a bank of times where you were like, I really don't want to go. This is going to be terrible and it was great anyways is so important for learning that association between sometimes being a little bit annoyed, sometimes being tired, too tired to go, you think, and actually being rewarded. And I don't want to say for that sacrifice, but rewarded for pushing through. Fourth tip, if you're really, struggling with like building community, pick two non-negotiable social days a week. This is something I've been employing since moving to London, consistently showing up despite
记住，这种不便仍然会带来回报。反思你自己的记忆，回顾过去，清晰地保留一份这样的记忆库：当时你觉得自己真的不想去，这会糟糕透顶，但结果却很棒。这对于建立这样一种联结非常重要：有时候觉得有点烦恼，有时候觉得很累——以为自己太累而不能去——但实际上却得到了回报。我不想说这是为了那种牺牲，而是为了坚持到底而得到的第四个建议，如果你真的很挣扎于建立社群，每周挑出两个雷打不动的社交日。这是我搬到伦敦后一直在采用的方法，不管状态如何，始终坚持出席。
your mood, just being in physical closeness to other people is a fantastic way to build the village, right? Back in the day, the village was really united by geographical closeness and people who lived next door to you and people who traveled with you and were maybe nomadic with you or who were in the hot next door. Like, yes, we've lost that closeness with the increase in, I guess, individualism and how spread out we are across the world. But every community, neighborhood, suburb, city still has those community hubs, still has gyms, pubs, libraries, choirs that you can go to.
与其他人保持身体上的亲近是建立村落的绝佳方式，对吧？过去，村落真的是靠地理上的接近凝聚在一起的，比如住在你隔壁的人、和你一起旅行的人、可能和你过着游牧生活的人，或者就住在隔壁的人。是的，随着个人主义的发展以及我们在世界各地分布得越来越分散，我们已经失去了那种亲密感。但每个社区、街区、郊区、城市仍然有那些社区中心，仍然有你可以去的健身房、酒吧、图书馆、合唱团。
So having two days a week where you're like, this is my, this is the, this is my, the price I pay to be in community and these are the days I'm going to devote just to being out there is highly effective. I would also say number five, kind of similar to this. Actually, it's totally not. It's completely different. But I'm like, oh, because it has to do with community. No, it's different. But number five, if you're struggling, invite your friends to do chores with you. Sometimes having those two big social days a week, that is a lot.
所以，每周抽出两天时间，心里想着：“这就是我为了融入社群而付出的代价，这些天我将专门用来走出去。”这是非常高效的。我还要说第五点，有点类似于这个。其实完全不是，完全不同。但我觉得，哦，因为它和社群有关。不，它不同。但第五点，如果你觉得艰难，邀请你的朋友和你一起做家务。有时候，一周有两个重大的社交日，那对某些人来说……
lot for some people, right? And it's expensive. It's expensive, especially if you live in a big city to go out and have to buy drinks, have to pay for the movie tickets, have to go out for dinner, twice a week. It's expensive. Dinner in London is like 40 pounds at the moment. Like doing that twice a week is sometimes not an option. Find those kind of more low effort things that you want to do with people. Chores are fantastic. Your ability to do chores. Your ability to do chores. with somebody, I think that that is a marker of whether you are good friends or not. It's been my best memories with my good friend, Aaron. It was when we lived in Canberra and we would just go to, what was it, the Dixon grocery store for hours. I had a terrible roommate at the time.
对某些人来说真的是个很大的负担，对吧？而且很花钱。这很花钱，特别是如果你住在一个大城市，要出去买饮料、买电影票、一周出去吃两次晚饭。这很花钱。伦敦的一顿晚饭现在大约要40英镑。一周做两次有时根本不在考虑范围内。去找那些你愿意和别人一起做的、比较低成本的事情。做家务就很棒。你和别人一起做家务的能力。你和别人一起做家务的能力。
Like, I really didn't want to be in the house. And we would just walk up and down and up and down those aisles. Sounds really lame. But you know what? Anything to be in closeness with somebody, I think is amazing. number six remember to keep track of milestones and consciously budget either time or money to make those milestones feel important for others i just feel like we don't celebrate each other enough and especially if you are like friends with a lot of really cool people who are always doing amazing things sometimes we forget that they still want to be celebrated and that we're all kind of little kids in a way who want somebody to remember our birthday and who want somebody to remember our first day
和某人一起做家务，我认为这是衡量你们是不是好朋友的标准。我和好朋友亚伦最美好的回忆就是当我们在堪培拉生活时，我们会去——那是叫什么来着？——去迪克森杂货店逛上几个小时。我当时有个很糟糕的室友。
of school, our first day of a new job, and who want people to remember that like, hey, that was a really hard thing and I'm getting through it and like that in itself deserves a reward. I think, I don't know, to speak from personal experience and to kind of break the fourth wall here, especially if you're watching on Netflix, like when Netflix, when this whole whole, Netflix thing happened. It was kind of sad in a way because I felt like this huge thing was happening and I was looking around for people to like celebrate with and some people who I really would have expected to be there for me and to want to celebrate with me for that, just weren't. And that really, that hurt and that really stung. And I think having that experience has made me realize,
就像，我真的不想待在家里。我们就会在那一条条过道里来来回回地走。听起来真的很无聊。但你知道吗？只要能和某人待在一起，我觉得就很棒。第六点，记得记录下重要的里程碑，并在时间和金钱上有意识地做预算，让这些里程碑对别人来说也显得很重要。我只是觉得我们互相庆祝得还不够，特别是如果你和许多非常酷的人做朋友，他们总是做着了不起的事情，有时我们会忘记他们仍然希望被庆祝，我们其实都像小孩子一样，希望有人能记住我们的生日，希望有人能记住我们开学的第一天
hey but am I doing that for others? And if I want to be part of the village, like I've got to be, sometimes you've got to set the example. And I think one of the greatest ways to show people that you care and that you listen is remembering just the smallest things. And every week putting $10, $20, $50 into an account just for social money and just for milestone money and celebratory money so that you can be a presence in somebody's life during their milestones. When they look back at the memory of a milestone, of a birthday, of an engagement, of a new job, of a new house, you are there and you are part of their kind of life story. Okay, we're going to take one more short break here, but when we return, let's talk.
新工作的第一天，并且希望有人能记住：“嘿，那是一件非常艰难的事情，我正在挺过去，这本身就值得奖励。”我想，我不知道，从个人经历出发，在这里打破第四面墙，特别是如果你在Netflix上收看的话，就像当Netflix，当整个这个Netflix的事情发生时。从某种程度上讲，这其实有点难过，因为我觉得这是一件天大的事，我在四处寻找可以一起庆祝的人，而有些我原本非常期望能在那里支持我、陪我庆祝这一成就的人，却偏偏不在。这真的，真的很伤人，也很刺痛。我觉得有了那样的经历让我意识到：
Also about when a friendship is perhaps becoming too one-sided. And when it's no longer inconvenience, it's a burden to be around those people. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
嘿，但我在对别人做这件事吗？如果我想成为村落的一部分，我就必须——有时候你得树立榜样。我认为向人们表达你关心和倾听他们的最好方法之一，就是记住哪怕最微小的事情。每周往一个账户里存10美元、20美元、50美元，专门用于社交基金、里程碑基金和庆祝基金，这样当别人经历人生重要时刻时，你就能参与其中。当他们回想起某个人生里程碑、某个生日、订婚、新工作、新房子的记忆时，你在那里，你成为了他们人生故事的一部分。好了，我们在这里稍作休息，但回来后，我们来聊聊。
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
还有关于当一段友情可能变得过于单方面时。以及什么时候它不再是不便，而是陪伴那些人的负担。请继续收听。2%。这是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all.
看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-P-P-Cent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？
all about cracking the aides. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes.
或者当坎耶说小布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。小布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，他畅谈了。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
关于破解80年代的瘾品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为瘾品。我随时都可以聊瘾品，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论瘾品的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在桌上还有艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《硬着头皮学》与我——你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯一起。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，但我们仍然在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在看计分板。生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。
Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要，还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once.
加入我的新播客《硬着头皮学》，和基尔·盖恩斯一起，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的IHeartRadio应用。搜索《硬着头皮学》并立即收听。在2023年，
It took an army of internet detection. detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你对某人篡改了这个特定测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试一次。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
I know I said we talk about when it's maybe time to kick somebody out of the village. But before that, one more tip because it has something to do with this, you got to fight more of your friends. I don't know what tip we're up to. Tip number seven, you have to voice frustrations and you have to learn how to fight with your friends. You deserve to fight with your friends. You deserve friends who will fight with you and for you because those are the same things. When I was younger, I know so many people in the same conflict to me was like that was the end. The first time somebody mentioned a grievance was the last time because the friendship was over.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
But having these little arguments, disagreements, sometimes having confrontation, I think nowadays shows that you care way more than those times that you just are like, you voice something and you're like done, this friendship's over. Because when you get to that point of being like, I'm so frustrated by this that saying it is the last word that I can say because I've already detached myself from this relationship in our mind. Like, that's not real friendship. Fighting with somebody when it's deeply uncomfortable and it's really,
我知道我说过我们要讨论什么时候可能是时候把某人踢出村落了。但在那之前，还有一个建议，因为它与此有关：你必须和你的朋友们多吵几次架。我不知道我们说到哪个建议了。建议之七：你必须表达挫折感，你必须学会和你的朋友吵架。你值得和朋友吵架。你值得拥有那些会和你吵架、为你而战的朋友，因为这两者是一回事。当我年轻的时候，我知道很多人在同样的冲突中觉得那就意味着结束。当有人第一次提到不满时，就是最后一次，因为友情已经结束了。
you don't know how it's going to go. That shows dedication. And I think that's what we all deserve. versus the ghost versus the fizzle. I think, again, I've said this on the podcast before. It is a real sign of emotional maturity, and that is how I knew my frontal lobe had developed and I had emotionally matured to another level
但有这些小争执、分歧，有时甚至是对峙，我认为在今天表明，你比那些只是表达了某事然后说“够了，这段友情结束了”的时刻要关心得多。因为当你到了那种地步，觉得“我对这个太沮丧了，说出来就是我能说的最后一句话，因为我已经从心理上把自己从这段关系中剥离出来了”的时候，那并不是真正的友情。当与某人争吵让人感到极度不适、且 naprawdę
was when I realized, like, again, if I have a problem, I find that the solution of saying it is the one that I will most likely pursue. It's just also, I think, the opportunity for a new beginning. And it's a way of kind of, I don't know, of relating to somebody else. And it's kind of like a bonding experience. The shift is so powerful, right? Like one of the best things is having a fight with your friend.
你不知道事情会如何发展时。这表明了奉献精神。我认为这才是我们所有人都应得的。而不是冷暴力或逐渐疏离。我想，再次重申，我在播客中说过这一点。这是一个真正的成熟的标志，这就是我如何知道我的前额叶皮层已经发育完全，并且我的情感已经成熟到了另一个水平。
And then three weeks later, being able to be like, oh my God, remember that fight we had? And we moved through it. And you stop treating every small thing, the things that come up naturally in friendships like an emergency. You stop panicking and performing and people pleasing your way. out of the discomfort and instead you get curious. You start seeing it as information. Like, okay, something is happening here. Something needs to be said. Something needs to change.
那就是当我意识到，同样的，如果我有问题，我发现说出来的解决办法是我最有可能去追求的。这也同样是获得一个新开始的机会。这是一种与他人建立联系的方式。而且它有点像一种凝聚的经历。这种转变是如此强大，对吧？比如最好的事情之一就是和你的朋友大吵一架。
Conflict is communication. It becomes the relationship showing you where your boundaries are, where your values are, where your needs haven't been spoken out loud yet. It's not a sign the relationship is broken. It's often a sign that it's becoming real and it's developing to a new level. I always say this as well and I'm going to stop lingering on this after this point I promise but once you have had your first fight with a friend and you've survived that, that's when you can call
然后三周后，能够说：“天哪，还记得我们吵的那架吗？我们挺过来了。”你不再把每一件小事——那些在友情中自然出现的事情——都当成紧急情况。你不再恐慌、表演，也不再用讨好型人格。
them a real friend. I remember having my first big falling out fight with one of my best friends in the world Meg and afterwards I was like cool so you're not ever going anywhere because if we got through this we can get through anything. Let's return to what I was originally saying. When do you kick
去摆脱那种不适感，取而代之的是你开始充满好奇。你开始把它当作一种信息。比如，“好吧，这里发生了点事情。有些话必须说出来。有些事需要改变。”
somebody out of the village? When is a friendship too inconvenient to keep up? Because there is a line and there's always going to be freeloaders in society and in the village who want the rewards without paying their social dues. I know I said not to keep score. I know I'm going to sound like a hypocrite. I know I said not to treat friendship like a point system. But there is a feeling you will get when you realize, oh wait, wait, I'm the only one invested here. A few busy months, I let that slide.
冲突就是沟通。它变成了关系在向你展示你的边界在哪里、你的价值观在哪里、你的需求在哪里还没有大声说出来。这不是关系破裂的迹象。它通常是一个标志，表明它正在变得真实，并正在发展到一个新的水平。我总是这样说，而且说完这一点后我不会再纠缠了，我保证：一旦你和朋友吵过第一架并且挺了过去，这时候你才能称呼
You know, I know I've had those really busy moments where I'm like, sorry, gals, I've got to cancel more plans than I can attend because I have to work and like life is busy and when you're the boss, like that's kind of just the way it is. And I'm really glad my friends gave me grace for that. Life gets busy. We're adults. We know that. Also, people have different energy levels. People have caring responsibilities. People have health problems.
他们为真正的朋友。我记得我和世界上最好的朋友之一梅格发生第一次激烈的决裂争吵之后，我当时想：“酷，所以你哪儿也不会去了，因为如果我们能挺过这个，我们就能挺过任何事。”让我们回到我最初所说的话。你什么时候把
also important to know that about your friends. But it's when, and this is the distinction, when you find yourself doing things for them, they would never do for you. Or specifically, they have had the chance to do that for you and they haven't. It's not about cutting them off at that point, but having that conversation, setting expectations, everyone can be unaware, everyone can have a rough season.
某人踢出村落？什么时候友情变得太不方便而无法维持？因为有一条底线，而且社会上和村落里总会有那些想不劳而获、不付社交会费却想得到回报的白吃白喝者。我知道我说过不要记分。我知道我听起来像个伪君子。我知道我说过不要把友情当成积分系统。但当你意识到“等等，等等，只有我一个人在这段关系里投入了心力”时，你会有一种感觉。几个忙碌的月份，我让它过去了。
But if you have expressed that you feel taken for granted or that you need more effort, they need to make plans, and they either dismiss you, guilt you, promise they to change and then they never do, repeat the same behavior, that's not a misunderstanding. You have been understood. That is a pattern. And patterns are what decide outcomes, not potential. Like I said, you want a village? Learn how to approach these hard conversations.
你知道的，我知道我也有过那些非常忙碌的时刻，当时我会想：“对不起啦，各位，我必须取消比能参加的更多的计划，因为我得工作，而且生活很忙，当你当老板时，情况差不多就是这样。”我真的很高兴我的朋友们对此给予了我宽容。生活很忙。我们是成年人。我们知道这一点。此外，人们的能量水平也不同。人们有照顾家庭的责任。人们有健康问题。
and also learn that this maybe not isn't necessarily the end. It might just be the beginning of a new way your friendship operates, but if they do something that you would never imagine doing to someone, to them, to a stranger, even to an enemy, it's not that this person doesn't deserve a village, they just don't deserve to be in yours. Your village has standards. And we're again, not talking about mild inconveniences.
了解你朋友的这些情况也很重要。但当——这就是区别所在——当你发现自己在为他们做一些他们绝不会为你做的事情时。或者具体来说，他们本有机会为你做那些事，却没有做。这时候并不是要直接切断联系，而是要进行沟通，设定期望。每个人都可能缺乏觉察，每个人都可能经历艰难的时期。
We're not talking about things that are apologetic for, but things that show a value mismatch, you're allowed to say this is not what our village does. I can't have you here. Cheating on a partner, hurting somebody else, betraying somebody else, lying. A village runs on values. What ones do you personally want to see in others
但如果你已经表达了你觉得被视作理所当然，或者你需要更多的努力，他们需要制定计划，而他们要么对你不屑一顾，要么让你内疚，承诺会改变却从未改变，重复着同样的行为，那这就不是误解。你已经被理解了。那是一种模式。而决定结果的是模式，而不是潜力。就像我说的，你想要一个村落吗？学会如何处理这些艰难的对话。
that you are committing to displaying yourself? Finally, the final criteria, I think, that a friendship has gone too far as too inconvenient is when it creates more stress than safety, and that's a feeling that you will, if you've ever been in the situation before you understand. Not every friendship needs to be deep, but it at least needs to be stable. If spending time with a friend feels like bracing for a terrible mood, managing their reactions, anticipating passive aggression, walking on edge, shelves, if it feels exhausting in like an emotional, soulful way, it stops being about companionship. I think it becomes a form of, like you're regulating them. And that is exhausting. And if you find yourself avoiding situations, being really excited when they cancel plans,
也要明白这不一定就是结束。它可能只是一种全新的友情运作方式的开始，但如果他们做出了你绝不会想象对任何人、对他们、对陌生人甚至对敌人做出的事情，那不是这个人不配拥有一个村落，而是他们不配呆在你的村落里。你的村落是有标准的。而且我们要再次强调，我们谈论的不是轻微的不便。
that is the biggest one. The moment you feel excited that somebody has canceled a plan, I think you need to place them elsewhere in your friend universe. And I wrote about this in my book, your friendship universe has three circles, the inner circle, the good, like the second circle and the third circle. Where someone sits in that circle determines essentially the nature of your relationship. The center of the circle, you should never be excited if somebody at the center of the circle cancels plants. Center of a circle, you should never be excited if they can't make it. Third circle, your expectations are a little bit different.
我们谈论的不是那些会道歉的事情，而是那些表现出价值观不匹配的事情，你有权说这不是我们村落做的事。我不能留你在这里。背叛伴侣、伤害他人、背叛别人、说谎。村落是靠价值观运转的。你个人希望在其他人身上看到什么样的价值观。
They're still in the galaxy. They just don't have to be a huge priority. You don't have to drop a friend, shift your expectations, shift their place in the friendship galaxy. Some final reminders before we go. Remember as well, I don't think I've spoken about this enough, but a village takes time if you don't have it yet, if it feels like you'll never have it.
而你又承诺自己去展现什么？最后，最后一个标准，我认为友情变得太不便、走得太远的时候，就是它带来的压力多于安全感，如果你曾经身处这种境遇，你就会懂这种感觉。并不是每一段友情都需要有多深厚，但它至少需要是稳定的。如果和某个朋友在一起感觉就像是在为糟糕的心情做心理准备、应付他们的反应、预判他们的被动攻击、如履薄冰。
I have to remind you everyone who has a village now at some point didn't have one and at some stage felt like they would never have it. Sometimes you have to destroy the old for the new as well. You know, I thought I had a village at university. I didn't and I was clinging to those people and trying to drag them into activities and into ways of engaging that I knew I enjoyed, but they weren't ever going to. And it just made me feel terrible about myself. When I got out of that environment, when I gave myself space, and time to just think about what I wanted in friendship.
如果在情感上、精神上让你觉得精疲力竭，那就不再是陪伴了。我觉得这变成了一种形式，就像你在调节他们的情绪一样。这太累人了。如果你发现自己总是逃避情况，甚至当他们取消计划时你反而感到非常兴奋。
You know, the way I thought about what I wanted in dating in Korea, it was very easy to separate myself and to understand that, you know, again, maybe the village I wanted didn't share the same values. Similarly, like, make sure you still have time for yourself. I know I place this big emphasis on, like, recognizing selfishness in boundaries, clothing, and not overusing the too-tied excuse, but social burnout is still real, especially if you're adapting to a new way of showing up.
那这就是最大的信号。当你发现自己对某人取消计划感到兴奋时，我觉得你需要把他们放在你的朋友圈宇宙的其他地方。我在我的书中写过这个，你的朋友圈宇宙有三个圈子，内圈、好一点的圈子，也就是第二圈和第三圈。某人在那个圈子里处于什么位置，基本上决定了你们关系的性质。处于圈子中心的人，如果中心圈子的人取消了计划，你绝不应该感到兴奋。中心圈子的人，如果他们来不了，你绝不应该感到兴奋。第三圈，你的期望会稍微不同一点。
My guideline for myself is always a day and a half or a day of alone time per week, nourishing alone time, just to make sure I'm not, you know, I'm pouring into my own cup as well. I want to be a good villager. A good villager has the patience and the time and the energy to do that. But we're all still learning.
他们依然在你的星系里。只是他们不必成为重中之重。你不必抛弃某个朋友，调整你的期望，调整他们在友情星系中的位置。在我们离开之前还有一些最后提醒。还要记住，我觉得我谈得还不够，但如果你还没有村落，如果感觉你永远不会拥有它，建立一个村落是需要时间的。
you know, we're all still learning our balances and I think getting corrections from friends is something you have to be open to. You also have to be open to doing that as well. And just having patience and forgiveness for people. I really think that's what we need more of. Thank you so much for listening if you have made it this far. If you are listening on Spotify, leave a comment down below. What are your tips for being a good villager that maybe I have an included. I would love to hear from you. Make sure you are following us on Instagram, TikTok. Remember, if you are listening to the podcast, we are now on Netflix, if you want to go and watch over there to get an even more intimate feeling. But I appreciate your interest in this topic.
我必须提醒你，现在拥有村落的每个人，在某个时刻也都曾没有过村落，而且在某个阶段也曾觉得自己永远不会拥有它。有时候你也必须为了新事物而摧毁旧事物。你知道的，我以为我在大学时有一个村落。我并没有，我还紧紧抓住那些人，试图把他们拉进我明明知道自己很喜欢、但他们永远不会喜欢的活动和交往方式中。这只是让我对自己的感觉糟糕透顶。当我走出那种环境，当我给自己空间。
I appreciate you being as fascinated by this as I am. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Good luck with the village. Good luck being a villager. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more
和时间去思考我在友情中究竟想要什么。
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
你知道的，就像我思考在韩国约会时自己想要什么一样，把自己剥离出来是非常容易的，并且去理解，你知道的，也许我想要的村落并不拥有相同的价值观。同样的，确保你仍然有时间留给自己。我知道我非常强调在边界、穿着上识别自私，不要过度使用“太累了”这个借口，但社交精疲力竭仍然是真实的，特别是如果你正在适应一种新的表现方式的话。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
我对自己的准则是每周总是留出一天半或一天的独处时间，滋养身心的独处时间，只是为了确保我没有，你知道的，我也在滋养自己的心灵。我想成为一个好村民。一个优秀的村民拥有这样做的耐心、时间和精力。但我们都还在学习。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
你知道的，我们都还在寻找自己的平衡点，我认为接受朋友的纠正也是你需要持开放态度的东西。你还得对做这件事保持开放。对人们保持耐心和宽容。我真的觉得这是我们最需要的东西。非常感谢你收听如果听到了这里。如果你在Spotify上收听，请在下方留言。有哪些关于如何成为一个好村民的建议可能是我没有提到的？我很想听听你们的意见。确保你在Instagram、TikTok上关注我们。记住，如果你在听播客，我们现在也在Netflix上，如果你想去那边观看以获得更亲密的感受。但我很感激你对这个话题的兴趣。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me,
我很感激你和我一样对这个话题着迷。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。祝你的村落一切顺利。祝你当个好村民一切顺利。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这是当电梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和意义重大。
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth?
84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《硬着头皮学》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习硬着头皮学。
on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once.
在我的新播客《吸取教训》中，请打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索《吸取教训》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改过某人的这份特定检测，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
这需要一大群网络侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款是如何被使用的。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格，女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app,
这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序上收听《爱情陷阱》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了我们在奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健康和适应力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方的 TWA%。在《回看》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我和说这都是一个重要的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
84年对我来说意义重大。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《吸取教训》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道他在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或您获取播客的任何地方收听并吸取教训。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克雷顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人出品。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。